in this video i'm going to show you how
i shot and edited an entire nature
documentary for the discovery channel in
my backyard
are you rolling there's spiders galore
here
[Music]
i'm going to be giving away this print
that i shot in this video of a snail
snailing around it's also signed to one
person that subscribes to my channel
turns the notifications below on and
comments below letting me know that
you've done so no matter where you are
in the world i'll send it to you this
video is brought to you by artlist which
is my new favorite source of sound and
music for all my videos from youtube the
whole way to tv broadcast documentaries
i just moved into this new house in cape
town which has the most incredible
garden
south africa is home to 43
43 40
43
565
species of insects and in this garden
alone there are probably hundreds long
story short i along with my small team
this is liam this is christian
i'm liam and i i just said that i
literally just said your name just like
what do you do
i
shoot and i do
liam struggles to define exactly what it
is that he does here because he does so
much i love you liam thank you
okay what do you do i'm an editor there
we go it's nice and simple we've been
working on this new series for the
discovery channel called the brew show
where i complete all the crazy ideas in
this idea
[Music]
it's a really dope series which has
involved casey neistat logan paul and
much more i'll link it below
now they've commissioned me to create a
documentary called big little world
where the intention is to show what the
world would look and sound like from an
insect's perspective what if you were
nick and ron and hanya strength the kids
in order to do this professionally
you'll need decent camera a probe lens a
stable slider of some sort a wireless
follow focus great sound and music which
is artless and a garden with all kinds
of bags
[Music]
so we're not even bothering to shoot any
sound here because i have to kind of
imagine what the sound would be like if
we were an ant as the audience so that's
going to be recreated in post using art
list which i'll show you how to do in a
bit
crazy bro
we are now on a mission to find as many
insects as possible in the garden we
have found one snail
oh sister frog
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
it's always great to move
uh to move through something
i think this hollow tree
oh no no no what
i uncovered and covered like a colony of
things here i lost my pretty bug
[Music]
the reason we track in with the probe
lens is because it amplifies the subject
it makes it even larger than life even
larger than the probe lens itself is
making the subject
so it just gives it this
beautiful feeling of
scale
yes
[Music]
with my youtube videos i usually prefer
to choose the music first and then cut
to the music but with nature
documentaries like this i prefer to
first make a rough cut so that i can
then use that
to help guide the selection of music and
then i make the cuts to the music
thereafter
does that make sense yes
[Music]
okay cool the rough cut of the edit is
now done and now it's time to find the
music sound effects are always done last
when you have what's known as a picture
lock which basically means when no
further changes will be made in the edit
[Music]
usually for big production documentaries
like this would use this professional
studio but it's not actually me that
does the sound and music
it's jason
[Music]
but i'm going to be using artless to
create something just as great or
probably greater than jason could do in
the first place
fair enough
using
none of these very complicated buttons
[Music]
okay that took all of
five minutes to find the perfect
soundtrack back to the edit
cool the edit is done with the
soundtrack what i'm going to do now is
mute the soundtrack and recreate all the
sounds using art list for example what
i'm going to need to do here with a
snail shot is layer a bunch of sounds on
top of one another to recreate the
scenario of what it would be like being
so close to the snail
cool now we're going to find the more
detailed sounds
pretty good
because artists have so many different
kinds of sound effects what we can do is
just look for weird things like goo
which okay this doesn't sound too good
but the goose on that i just found
earlier i mean it could work
okay it's starting to work
it's pretty good
okay great that's simple so what i'm
going to do is apply the same steps to
each clip
and then i'm going to be done and i'm
going to click export
export done
now i'm gonna show you the one minute
cut down of the feature length
documentary we made for discovery plus
which i'll link below
i hope you enjoy this cut
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
i hope you enjoyed watching that as much
as i did making it with my team
important to note if you click on the
link in the top of my description now
you get two months free of art list wait
that doesn't sound right you get two
mounts
for free
you know what i mean so yeah it's
as you've seen in this video it's really
really worth it yeah subscribe turn your
notifications below on comment below
letting me know that you've done so and
stand a chance to win the prince the
sign prince of the snail that i showed
you earlier and other than that don't
forget you're awesome bruh and i'll see
you next week
[ __ ]
[Music]
you